[Music]
hey everybody its charlie you've
probably seen the preview from Aquaman
that they dropped this morning there's a
bunch of different stuff we get to see
Black Manta with his comic-book helmet
mera Aquaman at Lana his Atlantean
mother there's a couple big Easter eggs
and the pictures that you've all
probably spotted James Wong the director
said a whole bunch about it and we have
news about the first trailer so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos let me know in the comments if
you want me to do some kind of Aquaman
related giveaway the movie isn't coming
out till later this year but obviously
they're ramping up for a big Comic Con
presentation I'll just read James wants
quotes that he gave about the movie so
he says the waterworld my movie takes
place in is so separate and so far apart
from previous DC movies it's like I'm
making my own sci-fi fantasy film
there's a whole new underwater world no
one has seen before in live-action
they're atlanteans riding great white
sharks giant octopus seven different
underwater kingdoms trench dwelling
cannibals and even sea dragons so
obviously James Wan notable horror film
director imbued a little bit of horror
into the film with some of these
undersea environments and some of these
monsters that were going to meet but
it's also meant to feel like this big
swashbuckling underwater adventure you
probably heard that James Wan quote
where he said seven kingdoms of Atlantis
and you're like wait a minute is that
the Geoff Johns seven kingdoms of
Atlantis is that the unite the seventies
er that they released when they first
announced Jason Momoa as Aquaman
you may remember it's almost been four
years since Jason Momoa was announced as
Aquaman I think it was like December
2014 when they were first like Jason
Momoa signs for picture deal to play
Arthur curry in the DC films they
released this picture that said unite
the seven but people are like are they
talking about the seven members of
Justice League because as it stands as
of Justice League there were six members
so people are like well Green Lantern is
the character that they don't have right
now is that gonna be seven is that what
unites the seven is supposed to mean but
if you haven't been a big Aquaman comic
book fan there was a Jeff Jones new 52
story line that was a building towards
Aquaman uniting the seven different
kingdoms of Atlantis so Atlantis is a
but it's also like a nation made up of a
bunch of different territories James Wan
is implying that we're gonna see all
seven in Aquaman as he becomes king of
Atlantis like this is all about Aquaman
vs ocean master for the kingdom of
Atlantis like he has to seize his throne
earn his birthright but in doing that he
has to unite all these disparate peoples
one of the other big nations is Zeb
alike Trench is another big nation the
actual trench where we'll probably see
that giant sea dragon that he teased he
doesn't appear anywhere in these images
but Dolph Lundgren is actually playing
nearest king of Zebulon the movie he's
gonna be Mira's father Mira is princess
of Zeb oh so it's like you know princess
from another nation getting married to
Aquaman then becoming king and queen of
Atlantis eventually in success however
many Aquaman movies that they want to
keep making I'll address that at the end
of the video too because we learned all
about the flash movie and I was planning
on making a video for that because it's
going a little more back to the future
than flashpoint from the comics the fact
that Nicole Kidman's at lana character
his Atlantean mother is still alive and
is still queen of Atlantis tells you a
little bit about the story that they're
doing because there's an animated movie
called throne of Atlantis I think I've
used it in most of the Aquaman videos
that I've done just to explain what's
going on with the Aquaman live-action
movie during that ocean master winds up
killing her seizing the throne making
war on the surface Aquaman has to stop
him the Justice League helps out so
obviously there's only gonna be shades
of that for the live-action movie like
they're pulling like I said a little bit
from Jeff Jones unite the seven seas new
52 storyline in the Justice League
throne of Atlantis story if you don't
know who oh [ __ ] master is he's being
played by Patrick Wilson obviously if
they're gonna be very comic book II with
a look of Black Manta they're also
probably gonna be very comic book II
with the look of ocean master because he
wears a very badass Atlantean lookin
helmet usually his modus operandi is in
collaborating with villains and other
rogue nations to take over the city of
Atlantis himself so this is Game of
Thrones element 2 but just to be clear
ocean master is the main villain of the
movie even though Black Manta is
probably one of the most famous Aquaman
villains if you don't know what the
relationships are either ocean master is
Aquaman
half brother so at Lana Aquaman's
atlantean mother had him with Thomas
curry the human who's dead as of the
events of this movie she then has to go
back to Atlantis to become its Queen
she's forced to marry another Atlantean
that man was ocean masters father so
ocean master is 100% Atlantean he would
technically become the next king but
he's pretty crazy and he wants to
destroy the surface world so obviously
that's why Aquaman who also has a claim
to the throne needs to take it but his
whole arc in the film is is that the
people of Atlantis view him as an
outsider because he's a half-breed he's
half-human in the people of the surface
world
think he's an outsider because he's half
atlante and so he doesn't fit in
anywhere those what that funny scene in
Justice League where he's sitting on the
lasso of truth is where he talks about
being an outsider never being part of a
group you know what I don't want to die
I'm young there's [ __ ] that I want to do
I just feel like I never really embraced
sea or the land I've been alone my whole
life being part of something bigger like
this maybe I'm scared because
I think that was beautiful you say what
about this they'll meet every prana I
know it was probably one of the funniest
moments from the film it does a good job
of showing you Jason Momoa strange he
can swing from funny to really badass at
the same time without being super silly
like Ezra Miller's flash I know you're
all wondering about black manta 2 James
Wan only said that he's part mercenary
full-time pirate who in his suit looks
like some crazy alien from outer space
obviously he's talking about his
comic-book helmet his suit just gives
him the ability to function and fight
people on the ocean floor as deep as
Atlantis is like it would crush a normal
human so he has to have special
technology that enables him to be down
there we don't really know what's going
on with his character before the events
of this movie why he hates Aquaman and
if it has anything to do with his
comic-book backstory I believe that
James once said that they're not doing
Aqualad in this movie but that doesn't
mean that they'll never do the character
if you're looking for a lot of really
good Black Manta you get that through
aqualad's character during Young Justice
season 2 because he's trying to
infiltrate his team so he pretends to go
team up with his father what they might
do for the live-action universe is pit
Black Manta against Aquaman
because maybe Aquaman killed his father
or killed somebody that he really cared
about his love interest in the comics is
Lucci 'hail she's from Zeb oh the same
place that Mira is from so maybe she
died somewhere in the backstory of the
movie but for whatever personal reason
he obviously hates Aquaman that's
basically his arc wants to take him down
he teams up with ocean master but if you
know anything about the ocean master
character he's a total [ __ ] that
only cares about himself cares about
power
he's very xenophobic hates the surface
world so he uses Black Manta the same
way he uses everyone else so it sounds
like they are planning to have an arc of
film so I'm not completely expecting
Black Manta to resolve his issues with
Aquaman during this movie they'll
continue into whatever sequel they wind
up making but a lot of that just depends
on how
things go with this first movie but let
me know in the comments what do you
think about the look of all this this is
what Mira actually looks like on film
freakin hot they actually released this
last year so obviously they've been
working on this for a long time the
reason we haven't seen a trailer yet is
because the special effects haven't been
finished but they just showed a finished
trailer off just the other day and it's
either the Kids Choice Awards or the MTV
Movie Awards that's happening on Monday
Jason Momoa is attending I believe he is
presenting an award there's a really
strong chance that that's when they'll
drop the trailer but they could always
wait till Comic Con so either it's gonna
be Monday or Comic Con what'll happen
next is is unless they drop like some
other really huge bomb in the next
couple of hours I'll work on a flash
movie video and explain what's going on
with that movie because it is actually
happening they're genuinely making it
but there have been some big changes in
what it's going to be so click here for
that new Wonder Woman 2 teaser and click
here for that new Avengers 4 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight